we talk about censorship and the young
adult reader I mean when I was in my
teens I was reading Judy Blume which
seemed chief anything yeah it was
fantastic around town yes she is which
was you know sort of edgy for that time
where is I know that the problems
present in those books are nowhere near
what's going on in today's world so talk
about censorship whether you stay away
from it whether you I know you're
talking more about other worlds yeah
things like that but there's there's
there is yeah so when you're writing
genre like science fiction there is a
certain freedom that can come from it
because you're not writing this world so
my books do have a lot of religious
elements in them but the religions in
them are not religions it exists now so
you're able to do a critique for example
of what that looks like without may be
directly offending somebody because
you're not criticizing their choice of
religion it's more looking at a future
Society likewise I think it's easier to
have diverse cast of characters there's
a reason why Star Trek the original
series was the first show to have a
black actress in a leading role because
there's something about it that frees
you from the cultural norms of now and
you're able to envision a different kind
of society in terms of what's happened
in young adult as its exploded a young
adult fiction I believe now outsells
adult fiction which is kind of a huge
deal adult fiction sales are down right
now young adult is still growing and so
as that's happened and as more people
are coming in and writing young adult
fiction you're seeing them tackle more
hard-hitting stories I have a friend who
wrote a book which is about a kid
dealing with the aftermath after his
mother has committed suicide so you're
seeing a lot of people tackling issues
that are pretty serious John Green's
very popular book Fault in Our Stars is
dealing with kids with cancer and what
that looks like for them so I think that
you're able to tackle a lot of pretty
serious issues in terms of censorship I
have heard stories from some of my
author friends about them encountering
some some backlash
over things they've written about I've
also heard of editors flagging cussing
and cuss words which is interesting a
lot of us feel strongly that you know
teenagers talk in a certain way and you
should be able to within reason have
some of that because I just don't think
it's realistic otherwise um you know in
my books I get to invent my own cuss
word because we have different worlds so
I can kind of get away with it and I
haven't had to tackle it the same way
that other authors who write
contemporary do but you know I just sort
of think I'm just so against censorship
in all forms I mean I think people can
choose what they want to read or don't
want to read nobody is forcing anything
on anyone but you know Judy Blume had a
huge impact on me and you know I can't
Tamora Pierce as Alana series had a huge
impact on me it's about a girl who wants
to be a knight so she binds her chest
and dresses up like a boy but there is a
whole scene I was just reading an
interview where she gets her period she
doesn't know what it is and it's this
whole it was so groundbreaking at the
time that Tamora Pierce who's amazing
wrote it it had a huge impact on me but
now that would almost be very bland like
I don't even think it would have the
same effect but back then like like Judy
Blume like Tiger Eyes yeah it was a huge
deal so yes I think that there has been
more of an acceptance but you know I
can't say that there isn't any
censorship still is there a list of
books that are our band that sounds I
mean I know that that Judy Blume was on
some list oh she was Harry Potter has
yeah Harry Potter's been banned there
was just recently the others a banned
books day where we celebrate banned
books yeah a lot of books that you would
think like Harry Potter to me seems very
tame that has been banned a lot 44 by
Christians for promoting sorcery or
something totally wacky in my mind to
that nature like promoting I don't know
things that are anti Christian I have no
idea but yeah the fact that there Harry
Potter has been targeted yeah and
there's a lot of like classic science
fiction books have been targeted a lot
over the years but yeah when my favorite
books Fahrenheit 451 is literally about
burning books and banning books there is
a whole plot line in my book the
thirteenth continuum where my underwater
world has fallen into a dark age which
is ruled by religion
contingent so everything from before
doom was destroyed in the great purging
so we I do deal with that in my book and
what happens the fallout of when you
start to censor and eliminate
information and then what happens to
that world so yeah I'm very strong
believer in access to all of these
things so but yeah I think we're still
dealing with some censorship the
internet though has also opened up a lot
it's so much easier to access things
they used to be back in the day you were
beholden to your in my case library or
maybe your local bookstore and I grew up
in a small southern town so I was sort
of at the mercy of what they were
willing to carry nowadays if my kid had
a Kindle you know like I would have
bankrupted my parents if I had one but
you know you can just access any book in
the world so I think it's pretty neat
you